if been in love it's sexy I guess say  something I can tell that there's  something here you know what do you  think okay we got to get style what the  situation Dean here was about to go to  work  ah telling you it's all over for me so  tragic wife Laura hug uh gorgeous well  we're friends  don't you ever get on that self-control  discipline are you guys having sex what  god no no huh we just had a first date I  don't know what to say to her do I like  her utility like her my two best friends  getting together what more could a guy  ask for good great  totally how was that back there you have  nothing to say to me me you exactly and  what am I telling you  love is the perfect moment that never  ends it's your perfect moment  finding the one is a false concept we  were just fulfilling our primal needs  like cavemen  okay I'm so sorry baby waiting like a  peach like melody what is that  you